it was the birth of his son that pushed
highly facile to leave home before
setting off he kept telling his wife but
he would do once he made it across the
Red Sea how his journey would change
their lives if only he could reach Saudi
Arabia two years have passed since his
final phone call from Yemen how can a
man that calls his family every day
disappear like this if he is alive he
would have called us some even say he
might be dead but it refused to believe
it I want to see him alive take care of
him if he's sick
or if I have to bury his body and
finally tell my son the truth about what
happened to his father is Faisal alive
and if so where is he so many questions
left unanswered this is where they last
heard from him in Yemen's capital sana
caught in the fighting between Houthi
rebels and Saudi Emirati coalition
forces are Ethiopian migrants trying to
make it to the rich Gulf countries they
have become the unexpected casualties of
the war in Yemen no one knows how many
migrants have died but the UN's
migration Organization says at least
2,500 have gone missing this year alone
it goes to show you two things one the
levels of desperation that forced people
to migrate but secondly how persuasive
the people smugglers and human
traffickers are in convincing them that
this might be a good time to make the
make the journey to Saudi Arabia through
Yemen because nobody's going to stop you
Ethiopians have made it back home bear
witness to the war in Yemen and the
humanitarian crisis there Abdul was
injured after people traffickers forced
him to fight on the front line to pay
his debt to get to Saudi Arabia they
asked me to be the soldier offering this
much money I told them I left my home
for work not to kill people and so they
punished me locked me underground in
Chains and then forced me to fight
whether in Yemen or in Libya conflict is
fueling the
trade in people trafficking armed groups
make empty promises to migrants
sometimes to children such as 13 year
old Ahmed who escaped from his
traffickers after overhearing their
plans to sell him I know the man who
wanted to sell me the broker who wanted
to make $1000 on me is from my village
in Ethiopia the UN estimates the booming
trade in people smuggling is worth a
hundred and fifty billion dollars a year
for many of the journey starts here in
the capital Addis Abeba because despite
the economic boom and the political
freedom this government is offering many
young people will travel days even
months in search for a new and better
life but at what cost faisal wife asks
herself her family is riddled with guilt
that he set off on his journey for them
my sole son has a message for his father
or for any other planning on following
in his footsteps come back home it's not
worth it we want you back
he says Nicholas Hawk al Jazeera I
deserve a bow